-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Hey, you made it.
Thank you for tuning in.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, a search for a new
Supreme Court justice has begun.
Today, it was announced that the
oldest justice on the bench,
Stephen Breyer, is retiring.
Yep, at 83,
Breyer only has two options --
either retire
or play quarterback
for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
[ Laughter ]
That's the only thing he's got.
Yep, Breyer said he wants to
retire so he can spend more time
looking like a wise shopkeeper
from a Hallmark Christmas movie.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it was clear Breyer's
been thinking about this.
During the last case,
the only question he asked was,
"When's nap time?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Breyer is retiring at 83.
Meanwhile, House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi just announced
she's seeking re-election
despite turning 82 in March.
And now other members
of the House
are speaking out
about her decision.
For example,
Congressman Don Young said...
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Next up,
Congressman French Hill said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Congresswoman Lucy McBath
said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Congressman Susan Wild
said...
[ Laughter ]
And Congressman Ted Budd said...
Congressman Barry Moore said...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-And, finally,
Congressman Neal Dunn said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Everyone had something to say.
At least --
Everyone's very vocal.
Speaking of Congress,
a bipartisan group of Senators
just announced legislation
to make the U.S.
more prepared for a pandemic.
Wow, great timing.
[ Laughter ]
Next week, they're gonna come up
with a plan to fight this
Y2K thing I keep hearing about.
[ Laughter ]
And listen to this --
Rudy Giuliani was asked
to turn over files for an
election lawsuit against him,
but he said that he can't
because the FBI
seized all of his computers.
[ Laughter ]
I'm no legal expert, but...
[ As Jeff Foxworthy ]
..."if all your evidence
from one investigation
is being used in another,
you might be going to jail."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Hey, this is cool.
Yesterday,
David Ortiz was elected
to the baseball Hall of Fame.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Big Papi.
And that's not
the only good news he got.
Check out the phone call that
Ortiz got later that same day.
Watch this.
-Hi.
I'm calling for David Ortiz.
-This is David Ortiz.
-Hi, David.
I'm Nathan.
I'm calling in regards
to your Seamless order,
the carnitas burrito
with a side of queso.
I'd like to apologize.
We're actually running
a little bit late.
But in order
to make up for that,
we're throwing in free chips
and guac for you.
-Yes!
[ Cheering ]
That's right.
Congratulations, Mr. Ortiz.
-Amazing.
-Free?
Wow.
-And guac?
-Yeah.
And, finally,
this is going viral on TikTok.
A police officer in South Dakota
showed up at a woman's door
for a pretty unusual reason.
Take a look at this video.
[ Doorbell ringing ]
-I know I'm not
who you're expecting, but...
-Hi.
-Your driver got arrested for
warrants he didn't take care of.
[ Laughter ]
So, I figured
I'd complete the DoorDash.
-[ Laughing ]
Thank you so much!
-Take care.
-Thanks!
-Come on.
[ Applause ]
He's a good man.
That's right.
The officer delivered
her DoorDash order
while an Uber Eats guy
took the driver to jail.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen!